and then the other half of me looks at
the current coronavirus situation
and looks at climate change it's like
yeah actually we we know what to do in
these situations too
and we're still doing nothing about it
hello my name is dr victoria patrician
i'm a professor of
environmental studies at the university
of southern california i have
a phd in geobiology and for the past 10
years i have been reconstructing past
climates on earth today we're going to
be looking at a number of different
disaster
movies and trying to figure out which
one of them did it right which ones did
it wrong
and how maybe they could have been
improved we're gonna start with one of
my all-time favorite disaster movies the
day after tomorrow
in which the north atlantic current is
disrupted which causes global cooling a
lot of weather catastrophes and the dawn
of a new ice age
oh here we go a giant tsunami is about
to
hit manhattan probably not no a tsunami
is going to be caused usually
by an earthquake so a tsunami happens
when the sea floor suddenly goes
up and down the east coast of the united
states is what's known as a passive
margin
there is nothing on the seafloor that is
going to cause a giant tsunami unless an
asteroid hits in the middle of the ocean
now what might happen is that if you
have the melting of the antarctic ice
sheet and
greenland ice sheet you will get sea
level rise that will start to flood new
york and in fact
this is something new york is very
worried about they have proposed a
billion dollar sea wall to try to keep
out rising sea water it will never be in
the form of a massive tsunami that comes
and
levels the city in 30 seconds
it's a super freeze could a
huge air mass come in and freeze
everything in its path that quickly no
that's not going to happen
so in order to do that you would
essentially have to
have to stop the sun from existing could
new york
be plunged into some sort of deep freeze
well there are a couple scenarios in
which yeah that could happen
in fact the northeast experience is
frequently now what is known as a polar
vortex
and that happens you get a lot of really
really deep
cold temperatures what's happening is
that normally
all of that really cold air stays around
the arctic circle
what's happening with climate change is
that
that air mass is destabilizing and it's
dipping
down into the continental u.s
which is actually kind of hard sometimes
for people to wrap their minds around
because the polar vortex reaching into
new york or boston or anything like that
is an
actual effect of warming in the arctic
so
it's seemingly getting colder at times
is a direct result of
warming instead of cooling our next
movie is the swarm
which i don't know much about uh but
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
movie so we will learn about it together
for more than 20 years scientists have
known that a swarm of killer bees has
been headed towards the united states
now warner brothers
[Music]
the swarm is now a movie i must watch
immediately but
could this happen so yeah there are
there are animal migrations that do kind
of
invade i don't think their target is the
human race
most of the time they're mostly looking
for flowers can a swarm of something a
plague
of locusts something like that come and
move into the united states sure
absolutely there's no reason to
say i mean it's not gonna it's not gonna
be like us in the the 70s roberts
taking them on with flamethrowers but we
are definitely seeing
you know insects creeping up into our
domain that haven't been here before
in los angeles we used to never have
mosquitoes
now we have a lot of mosquitoes that
carry things like west nile maybe zika
and
the big culprit behind us is that so
much of our climate is changing that
the insects are now moving north looking
for more favorable
climates so could a giant swarm of
killer bees invade texas uh it might not
be bees it might be
mosquitoes that carry disease with them
but yeah sure we'll give this a why not
our next movie is wall-e uh an adorable
cautionary tale where excessive
consumerism has really made the earth an
enormous
garbage dump and the human race now
lives on
a spaceship waiting for the day when
they can return to earth and when life
is again
possible on earth i love this movie
i got the space junk pretty right is the
premise of
wall-e possible could we have actually
trashed this planet to the point where
all of uh humanity has to leave and go
someplace else
and then we're just going to send some
robots back in to clean it up
i don't think it would actually have a
little more optimistic i don't think it
would ever
get to the point where we would actually
take off on a spaceship
if only because we don't have the
ability to get on a spaceship
and go someplace else at this moment so
we really do have to sort of take care
of what's here because there is no other
option for us
at this point i thought it was actually
really interesting that they had the
wind turbines
up there in the beginning there's a big
problem in
environmental studies right now with
even if you have renewable energy if you
have solar panels or if you have wind
turbines
there are parts of those that are
enormous especially the
giant fiberglass blades they're huge and
they're not recyclable we don't really
have good
answers to that yet so overall i'm
optimistic that no we would
actually pump the brakes on this before
we got as far as wall-e
and then the other half of me looks at
the current coronavirus situation
and looks at climate change it's like
yeah actually we we know what to do in
these situations too
and we know how it's damaging our
country damaging the world and we're
still doing nothing about it
so i cling to optimism i know they're
very smart people
very passionate people who my students i
see are working on these problems
but you know there's there's a long road
that helps up next we have
san andreas in this movie the san
andreas fault ruptures
causing a bunch of major earthquakes
around the fault
and the only person who can save the day
is of course
the rock
hollywood signs going down first of all
uh if the san andreas fault ruptures
like the big one
the big one if you have let's say a
magnitude
8 earthquake in los angeles will all of
the buildings
start to crumble instantly probably not
the way
uh they show in this movie all of the
buildings in los angeles
are built to withstand a certain amount
of shaking so even
if you've ever been in los angeles in an
earthquake what you see is the buildings
kind of sway back and forth
they're on rollers so what you have in
an earthquake is is the first
wave hits and that's the shaky up and
down wave okay
that is what's known as the p wave then
what you have um
is the s wave the s wave comes in and
that's the roll
now if you have one big enough and
sustained enough like the earthquake
took enough time
eventually those safety measures aren't
going to do anything anymore and your
buildings would start to fall
would it be that like all of downtown is
affected um
probably not because the san andreas
fault doesn't actually run
through downtown los angeles san andreas
fault the system is actually a little
more
north and east of here now if there was
a big
earthquake on it uh depending on where
it was in the fault that
energy could get reflected back into the
la basin
and take out downtown los angeles at
least do a huge chunk of damage
but it's not actually going to happen in
downtown
l.a there's there are other faults of
course going through the entire city but
the san andreas
does not up next is mad max fury road a
personal favorite of mine we're an
apocalyptic wasteland
uh where both water and oil have become
incredibly scarce this has collapsed
civilization
and turned the world into a desert
wasteland
it is by my hand you will rise
from the ashes could we ever worldwide
be in a scenario
where fresh water is so scarce that we
have entered a mad max fury road
scenario or the entire globe
probably not basically with climate
change you can just think of wherever
you live
whatever the worst part of your weather
is that's the thing that's going to get
worse
so here kind of the worst things we have
to worry about are drought
wildfires and high temperatures in the
summer
and that's what we can expect to get
worse we can expect
less fresh water we can expect more
intense storms delivering less water
overall
we can expect way more over 100 degree
days
but if you look at say what's going to
happen in the eastern u.s
or maybe in the gulf regions so texas
louisiana what can they expect it's
going to be more intense storms
more flooding more hurricanes things
like that so
there will still be water on earth it
will still
rain unless we've done some kind of
horrible
nuclear war scenario where we literally
screwed everything up but in that case
chances are humanity is not making it
anyways so there would still be fresh
water in some
areas just not in all the areas it's
also
interesting to note that these movies
are filmed in australia and australia is
already at this point you know largely a
desert so
could it could it get there well parts
of australia are already there and as
we've seen
the huge wildfires that have have spread
through
the east coast of australia have really
kind of done a number so we're already
seeing these things start to happen
so it's going to be very very region
dependent on whether or not you get to
live out your favorite mad max fury road
scenario so thank you for watching
disaster movies with us today
it's really interesting to see what
hollywood kind of continually does right
and continually does wrong in these
scenarios you know hollywood has really
latched on to the idea of
climate as an impending disaster and
they're right in that respect it is this
slow moving train wreck coming our
way uh what they get wrong is that it
will be a lot of
small changes rather than some big
technological thing
uh that that comes and saves those songs
so keep watching disaster movies they're
fun they're enjoyable i love them
just keep in mind that a lot of these
things don't have an actual basis in
science and could probably never happen
you are never going to freeze solid in
30 seconds so
go on get in the water
you